[Music]
frodo baggins may come across as a bit
distant on the big screen but he's being
consumed from the inside out as he tries
to step
up and save the world here's a complete
backstory that led to this humble hobbit
playing such a crucial role in
middle-earth history
in order to understand frodo's origins
it's worth taking a step back to
consider the culture he grew up in
the lord of the rings author j.r.r
tolkien goes to great lens throughout
his writing to highlight the quiet yet
profound differences that make orbits
distinct from the dwarves
men elves and wizards that they share
middle-earth with
though it's rumored that hobbits are
distantly related to human beings
they rarely fraternize with them early
in their history hobbits were split into
three large subgroups the stores get
along with men fairly well they enjoy
boating an activity that is uncommon for
hobbits and can even grow facial hair
the hartfords are close friends with the
dwarves and are the first hobbits to
initiate the custom of living
underground
the fallow hides like the elves and are
the most adventurously tempered of the
bunch arbit culture is well known for
its relaxed rural nature
they're not big fans of machines or
industry preferring a humble life with
plenty of access to good food and drink
despite their aversion to new things
hobbits are still quite skilled and
industrious when they need to be they
have better vision than humans their
thick feet make navigating rough terrain
a breeze and their famously short
stature comes in handy
more than you might think the history of
the hobbit stretches back to the
earliest days of the third age
at this time they lived in the north
eastern region of middle earth between
murkwood and the misty mountains
as life becomes dangerous for them the
different clans begin to move west in
search of greener pastures eventually
migrating over the misty mountains
it's likely that a few of the stores
stayed behind settling near the great
river anduin
this sets the stage for gollum's life
centuries later a distant hobby relative
of the stores and his discovery of the
one ring
as they move west many hobbits settle
into the area around debris
but it's not until the year 1601 of the
third age that the halflings finally
colonize the area that becomes known as
the shire
when settled the hobbits and their
descendants lived comfortably for
centuries
until the events of the war of the ring
force them to take their place
among the peoples of middle-earth as
they arrived in the shire the hobbits
become part of the dying kingdom of arno
a nation of men in the sister kingdom of
gondor some hobbits even claim to have
sent archers to help in one of arnold's
wars
however when the nation crumbles 500
years later the shayar hobbits declare
their independence which lasts for a
thousand years
as an independent people they begin to
elect a leader called athene to help
guide them
the first stain bucker of the marriage
ultimately founds the brandy burke
family
after a few hundred years one of his
descendants leads the brandy bugs from
the shire to colonize a neighbouring
region
that becomes known as buckland though
closely connected to the shire buckland
operates at his own independent entity
frodo's mother bramula brandy buck hails
from the small colony of hobbits fans of
the movie will recognize the name
buckleberry buckland's main village
it's mentioned in the fellowship of the
ring as frodo and his companions flee
from the black riders and cross the
river on the buckleberry ferry
while his mother grew up in buckland
frodo's paternal family traces its roots
completely to the shire his father's
family is much younger historically
speaking
the first bagen's balboa baggins shows
up not much more than a century before
bilbo was born the bagenses established
himself quickly but mostly concentrate
around the village of hobbiton they
intermarry with several powerful hobbit
families bilbo baggins calls out several
in his famous speech
my dear baggins and buffins
this actually makes frodo and his
companions pipping and merry distant
cousins
while the baggins family has a less
prestigious pedigree than the brandy
bucks frodo's father's family is still a
well-known shire staple by the time the
ring bearer shows up on the scene
frodo baggins has born to drogo baggins
and bermulla brandy burke on september
22nd
in the year 1368 of the shire reckoning
frodo's family spends a good deal of
their time in buckland this
is largely due to the fact that frodo's
father is a great patron
of food and the master of buckland is
famous for his elaborate dinners
unfortunately one evening frodo's
parents decide to go boating in the
moonlight after dinner while on the
water their boat tips and both drown
it isn't long before several versions of
the events of the evening begin to
circulate
some claim that drogo's enormous wage
sank the boat while more sinister rumors
claimed that premular pushed her husband
in
and he pulled her along with him
whatever the specifics the event leaves
frodo
orphaned at a very young age after the
death of his parents
frodo spends much of his youth in brandy
hall a massive underground hobbit
enclave that is always filled with
hundreds of his brandy burke relatives
while there frodo establishes himself as
a bit of a troublemaker in the
fellowship of the rink
farmer maggie recollects that frodo was
one of the worst rascals he's known
probably due to his repeated attempts to
steal from the farmer's crop of prized
mushrooms in his early 20s frodo is
adopted by his wealthy cousin bilbo who
brings him back to hobbiton to live with
him at bag end
their age difference is significance
however and frodo ends up calling his
older relative
uncle bilbo they're two peas in a pot
and they settle into a life of
comfortable bachelorhood at back end
they spend more than a decade together
in an uneventful existence before
bilbo's fateful 111th birthday
frodo and bilbo share the same birthday
september 22nd
in fact in the fellowship of the ring
bilbo even states this as a condition
for why he feels frodo should come live
with him by living together they can
comfortably share their birthday parties
the bachelors have quite the annual to
do and go about hosting drone birthday
parties
when bilbo's 111th and frodo's 33rd
birthday fall on the same year they
decide to plan for a special celebration
111 years old is a particularly
respectable age for a hobbit to reach
and 33 is the point at which hobbits
consider their young ones have come of
age the event becomes a bigger deal than
anyone expected however
because unbeknownst to them bilbo has
decided to leave
my this would be a night to remember
bilbo chooses to abandon his comfortable
life again in the most dramatic fashion
he completely destroys his already shaky
reputation by using his magical ring
to vanish before the eyes of all the
party guests when the dust settles frodo
finds himself in possession of bilbo's
rink
and the unexpected new owner of bag end
where he continues to live his carefree
life for another 17 years
everything changes for frodo when he
turns 50 years old it's at this point
when gandalf the wizard arrives at his
doorstep
gandalf explains that the ring frodo has
held on to for so long
is actually the one ring forged
originally for sauron the dark lord
this revelation is the start of a grand
quest that leads the reluctant hobbit to
the village of brie
seeking council in rivendell through the
dark minds of moria
across the lands of gondor and
ultimately to the bleak land of mordor
the foreboding domain where the ring was
forged on his journey
frodo learns to overcome his fears and
accept his calling as a ring bearer he
is tasked with carrying the one ring
back to mount doom
and casting it into the fires of the
volcano it's the only way to destroy the
powerful relic and the only hope for the
free peoples of the world
along the way he tames gollum and uses
the miserable wretch as a guide to help
him and his friends somewise find their
way into mordor
meeting golem proves vitally useful
because when frodo finally stands at the
cracks of doom
he finds that he doesn't have the will
to destroy the powerful golden ring
instead he succumbs to temptation and
claims it as his own
also consumed by desire gollum chooses
that moment to attack the ring bearer he
bites off frodo's ring finger before
slipping and falling
ring in hand into the fiery depths below
after his harrowing adventures that span
much of the lord of the rings frodo
makes his way back to his home in the
shire unfortunately when he arrives
frodo and his friends don't find the
idyllic landscape that they left behind
the shire has become overrun by ruffians
backed by a man calling himself sharky
the criminal leader is none other than
saruman the fallen wizard who has fled
to the shire after his defeat to orthong
by gandalf
in response frodo sam merry and pippin
use their newfound experience as
warriors to rally their fellow hobbits
together they overthrow their oppressors
the conflict dems with the brigands
force from the shire
and the demise of saruman after the
scouring of the shire comes to an end
life begins to settle down again however
on the anniversary of being stabbed by
one of the black riders on weathertop
frodo admits that the wound still
aches it's been four years to the day
since we're the top sat
it's never really healed more
significantly each year on the
anniversary of the destruction of the
one ring
frodo falls into a despondent sickness
and despair a spiritual toll of bearing
the ring was so great
that frodo realizes that he will never
find true peace in middle earth
though frodo's personal life is filled
with sorrow and pain during these years
the retired adventurer doesn't remain
idle along with helping to restore his
home he spends a period of time serving
as the interim mayor of michel delving
capital of the shire he also spends a
great deal of time working on the red
book of westmarch this famous tome was
begun by bilbo who used it to record
among
other things the story of his own
adventures frodo organizes a manuscript
and then adds his own accounts of the
war of the ring he gives the book an
appropriately epic title the downfall of
the lord of the rings and the return of
the king
while frodo is the primary author of the
red book his friends sam
pippin and mary add to it in various
ways
exhausted and worn down frodo finally
makes the hard decision to leave middle
earth after the war of the ring
arwen even star daughter of the great
elf elrond
now the queen of gondor chooses to
become mortal and stay with her husband
aragorn her ability to make this
sacrifice stems from her grandfather's
efforts
to save the world as chronicled in the
silmarillion arwyn's mortality means she
can no longer travel to the west with
the rest of the elves she gives frodo
her spot as a passenger and one of the
ships that will take him to the blessed
realm
a sort of heaven on earth for the
immortal beings few mortals are allowed
to make this trip
but given their roles in the destruction
of the one ring both bilbo and frodo are
awarded the special
privilege and so frodo leaves his
friends and middle earth behind
tolkien doesn't provide any more clues
about what frodo's life is like on the
other side of the water
instead he leaves us with a single
tantalizing line near the end of the
return of the king
and then it seems to him that the grey
rain curtain turned all to silver glass
and was rolled back and he beheld white
shores and beyond them a far green
country
under a swift sunrise check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
lord of the rings are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one